Yeah.
Amen. What a blessing. Amen.
Yeah, it's, uh, it's always encouraging to see
how God's been at work among us for the last 60 years.
We're celebrating that this month,
but we also believe that God wants
to do even more abundantly than he has in the past,
over the next 60 plus years.
Uh, so we're looking forward
to that and trusting him forward.
If I haven't had the privilege of meeting you yet,
my name's John, one of the pastors here, love to meet you.
Uh, we'd love to get to know you as we can.
And so we're studying parts of the book
of one Corinthians right now, just looking at the idea
of faithfulness, both God's faithfulness to us,
but then also how that enables us to be faithful to him.
And so take your copy of God's word.
Turn there with me if you can.
One Corinthians chapter one, the start of it.
First nine verses is where we're gonna be today.
One Corinthians one, one through nine.
As you find it, as you settle in to that, I, I, I want us
to do a little thought experiment together to get started.
I was talking to a pastor friend of mine this week
and uh, he had a great idea similar to this, but,
but what I want, I want, I want us to do, I want you
to do is, is to examine your life and,
and think about like your, your past,
your present, and your future.
And so think, think about your past,
like the choices you've made, uh, the sins you've committed,
failures, successes.
But just think primarily about the way you view your past
and then then your present, your circumstances today, like
where you're at in life, what's going on,
what you're experiencing, and then think about your future.
So just think about those three sections of life.
But in doing so, here's what I want us to start with.
I want you to consider how you would think about your past,
your present, and your future.
Yet in doing so, you would remove the faithfulness of God.
In other words, how would we view our past, our present,
and our future if God was not faithful?
Now, here's how I would answer that.
At least looking back at my past
without God's faithfulness, it'd be a lot of regret
over choices I've made, sins I've committed, habits I had,
I'd also be defined by what other people think about me
or say about me or have done.
To me. If I think about my present circumstances
without God's faithfulness, I,
I'd be disappointed I didn't have more.
I'd also be really sad that not everybody loves me
and that would really sway and and change my life.
And then looking to the future without a faithful God,
how would I view my future?
Well, it'd be a lot of fear over what could happen
to me or to my family.
Even thinking about death,
I would wonder what, what even happens.
I would be so afraid of that moment.
So what would change then
when we do include the faithfulness of God?
Like how does God being faithful change the way
that we view our past, our present, and our future?
And that's what we're gonna see today.
This reality that we can hold fast the confession
of our hope without wavering for he
who promised is faithful,
that we can hold fast to this confession of hope
because he who promised is faithful.
That's what one Corinthians one, one
through nine will show us.
It'll show us God's faithfulness, past, present, and future
and how that changes our lives today.
Let me read it. Paul called
by the will of God to be an apostle of Christ Jesus
and our brother Sese to the church of God that is in Corinth
to those sanctified in Christ Jesus called
to be saints together with all those
who in every place call upon the name
of our Lord Jesus Christ, both their Lord
and ours grace to you and peace from God, our Father
and the Lord Jesus Christ.
I give thanks to my God always for you
because of the grace of God
that was given you in Christ Jesus,
that in every way you were enriched in Him, in all speech,
in all knowledge, even
as the testimony about Christ was confirmed among you, so
that you're not lacking in any gift as you wait
for the revealing of our Lord Jesus Christ
who will sustain you to the end guiltless in the day
of our Lord Jesus Christ.
God is faithful by whom you were called into the fellowship
of His son, Jesus Christ,
our Lord God.
We need you to open our eyes and our minds
and our hearts to see what you want us
to see today from this passage, from your word
for us to see our past, present,
future from your perspective, to be doers
of the word, not hearers only.
God, we know around the world right now, there's a lot
that is troubling.
Pray for peace in the Middle East
And it can create fear.
So God, I pray that even today in this passage,
you would remind us of your faithfulness, your goodness,
and we would be able to trust you more.
Thank you. God, help us. Holy Spirit illuminate this to us.
In Jesus' name we pray. Amen.
So first, let's look back to our pasts,
how God was faithful there using one Corinthians one
to answer the first question that we have.
What has the Lord Jesus Christ done?
What has Jesus done?
What has God done looking at our past?
Well, first we saw here in this passage,
he has sanctified us, right?
That's the first thing we can see right away,
that he has sanctified us.
That Paul wrote this letter to the church in Corinth
and then he calls them to those sanctified in Christ Jesus.
That word sanctified means made holy.
It means set apart from the regular, the normal.
He even added the phrase called to be saints.
Not some like super class of Christian
that gets a stained glass window made out of you.
Like that's not what we're talking about. Saints.
We're talking about those who are holy ones in God, right?
Holy ones a saint.
What he's talking about in other words is
for those God has drawn to salvation, anyone
who calls upon the name of our Lord Jesus Christ,
he has set apart, has made holy
as a Christian, he's made them acceptable.
He's made them able to be in his presence.
Now where as a sinner we can't, but now as a saint we can.
But notice the sphere in which this happens.
He says, those sanctified in Christ Jesus,
he's not just saying those sanctified, poof, it happens.
He just kinda randomly does it.
It's sanctified in Christ Jesus.
Paul showed here, it's through Christ that we are made holy
not our own actions.
It's his perfection that counts us as perfect.
When we believe it, it's his blood
that cleanses us completely to make us
holy in Christ.
In fact, nine times
in just these nine verses the name Jesus Christ shows up
like Paul can't do it enough.
He can't say it enough that this is the point.
It's in Christ. It's all about him. He is our salvation.
He is our hope. Don't miss that.
But just think for a second what that means.
That if we're sanctified in Christ Jesus, what that means,
the tense of sanctified means it already
has been accomplished.
It's already happened. This is not a future. This is a past.
What that means is that if you're in Christ,
you are already holy.
You're already a saint.
That's how our faithful God sees you Christian.
I think about that. That's
how our faithful God sees you, meaning all those things
that I regret about my past.
He has exchanged it for forgiveness.
He's exchanged the regret with forgiveness
because I am sanctified.
I have been sanctified in Christ.
So let's live differently because of that, right?
Like let's think differently about our past.
But look what else he's done.
He's not only sanctified us, he has enriched us.
It says Paul's writing to this church
and he says he's enriched you.
Church, like verses four through seven, this grace
of God has enriched the Corinthian believers
and he talking about spiritual gifts.
They've been given these gifts.
It's, it's a enriching kind of idea.
In fact, it's the same word. This gift.
And grace has the same root word in Greek chorus
that the grace is a gift and the gift is God's grace.
It works together.
But notice Paul wrote in verse five,
God had enriched them in every way.
He's saying God had given them all the gifts they needed.
This church didn't lack anything that God wanted them
to have for the purpose he had for them.
Which later he goes on in chapter 12 here
to talk about the church that he's referring
to here being the body of Christ.
That there's all these different parts members
that have all been given different functions,
different gifts, we might say, for the good of the whole,
for the good of the other parts,
that they're reliant on one another for the full functioning
of the body according to what God has for it.
So just to be reminded of this, for you
to be reminded believer, you
and I have been gifted by the Lord God Almighty,
if we're believers, you
and I have been graced with the gifts
that God wants for us.
What that means is that you're not worthless,
you're not unnecessary.
Your past might say you are
or others might say you are because of your past.
You are not worthless, you're not unnecessary.
I need your gift. You need my gift.
We need each other in the body of Christ so
that we can grow into God's maturity He has for us.
Ephesians forcep, every
part is critical.
So again, while, while on our own without the faithfulness
of God, we might look back at our past with regret,
with shame, disappointment.
See what the Lord Jesus Christ has done.
He's sanctified us. He's enriched us.
He's saved you. He's made you holy. He's gifted you.
We can be sustained
because he who promised has always been faithful
yet is he faithful today?
I know it's an easy answer, Greg. It's quick.
Yes, but there's some days
it's not that quick, right?
There's some days that it's not as easy to say that
when we look around at our current circumstances
and we get discontent real fast or we get disappointed
because it's not this way or we get distracted by this
or that, it's not maybe as easy to say,
yeah, he's faithful today.
Our problems can so easily overwhelm us.
So how is he faithful today? That's the question past, yes.
How is the Lord Jesus Christ working and faithful today?
What's he doing today? We look at our present.
Well first he's purifying us. We look at this passage.
We know we can piece together some of the elements here
that says, God is purifying us as believers.
And so track this. Remember, he has sanctified us.
So we already are that
and he's called us.
It says to be saints,
which includes both the past action
and the ongoing action as a result.
You can even see it here in verse eight,
that on the day Jesus returns, he's going
to declare us guiltless.
That's a word that means blameless in a legal
sense like so.
So what this is saying is like you and I are going to appear
before the judge's bench on that day
and our guilty record will have been erased like we will
have been it.
It will have been sent away.
It's like it never even happened
'cause Jesus didn't sin in any way.
So ours is clean because his is standing for us.
It's all covered by Jesus Christ.
In fact, it's what Romans eight says.
Who shall bring any charge against God's elect?
It's God who justifies means there's no more
usability for those who are in Christ.
Now we know that that's coming someday, that's future.
But it's also a reminder
of the believers' position now like today,
that just as we will be on that day,
that's the way we even are today, guiltless.
Now I know you're looking at your life like I just sin this
morning on the way to church, right?
So the point is even that's covered.
When God would stand you
before the bench so to speak, it's covered.
His blood covers past, present, future sins.
It's already covered. So here's the point.
If that's who we are, like if we're
already saints already, holy already guiltless,
here's what Jesus is doing today with that ongoing action.
He is making us more like that reality.
He's purifying us.
He's bringing us closer to the way
that we will actually be on that day.
It's a process we call sanctification.
Now he has sanctified us,
but the process of sanctification is
making us more like that.
Now we're matching our reality. God's making us more holy.
He's making us more pure.
It's what one Thessalonians four 13 says, this is the will
of God for you, your sanctification.
And then he gives a list of actions
that happen in your daily life.
So he's saying sanctification is a process.
So what Paul is saying, check this out, tie this together.
What Paul is saying here is that as believers,
we just need to live out who we already are.
If we already are sanctified, holy guiltless,
just start living it out.
You don't have to try to be it, you already are it.
So just live it out. Sounds
a lot easier than it actually is.
I know, but that's the point he's making.
He's working to purify you,
to make you more like you will be one day.
That also means though,
when we look at our present circumstances instead
of lamenting, instead of looking
around and worrying about my circumstances,
it's not the way I would want it disappointed.
Instead, I could see those circumstances as God's means
to purify me, to sanctify me,
to almost look at these things
and say, thank you, God, for the hard things
because I know you're shaping me through those things,
to purify me, to sanctify me.
And I'm talking about even that hard relationship at work,
even that that injury that just won't seem to heal,
even that sickness that never goes away.
Even even that consistent financial struggle
that you face every month, even
that in all of it.
In all of it, I can know.
See if you can fall along. He's still working on me
to make me what I ought to be.
Right? You remember that I'm, I learned
that song 40 years ago and it still just comes up.
But that's true, isn't it?
He's still working on me to make me what I ought to be
and what I will be one day.
And he uses even hard times to do that.
As Romans five says, we rejoice in our sufferings
knowing that suffering produces endurance.
Endurance produces character. Character produces hope.
Hope does not put us to shame
because God's love has been poured into our hearts
through the Holy Spirit who has been given to us,
suffering leads to
that if we let it.
So he's purifying us. That's what he's doing right now.
He's purifying us. But he's also notice
what it said in one Corinthians one,
he's also sustaining us.
We saw how he's faithful in the past,
sanctify in rich gift.
He's purifying and he's sustaining us today.
One Corinthians one, look at verses seven
and eight again so that you're not lacking in any gift
as you wait for the revealing of our Lord Jesus Christ,
who will sustain you to the end guiltless in the day
of our Lord Jesus Christ.
So Jesus is coming back someday.
Yet the Corinthians and you
and I are tempted to think, man, how?
How can I even make it
that far my life?
Look at the world. How can I make it?
They they needed to be reminded how they could even make it
verse nine, because God is faithful,
because God is faithful.
In fact, the original language puts the emphasis on faithful
by putting it first in the sentence it says
essentially, faithful is God.
Faith, like this is what you need to remember.
Faithful is God. He
is faithful.
'cause I know on some days I, I know on some days
how quickly I am tempted to think
that everything's falling apart in my life.
It's all collapsing. How can I even make it through the day?
And I tend to, this is the phrase
that came the last couple months.
I tend to worry it out
where I'm thinking about the next
steps of whatever could happen.
Well, what if this happens? Well then that's gonna happen.
Well, if that happens, then this is gonna happen
and then this is and so on and so forth.
And you just keep going out. Right?
And I get all worked up about step 45 when step
two might not even happen.
Anybody else do that? Am I the only one?
Maybe I think like
don't worry it out
because what I'm afraid of in that moment, what I'm doing in
that moment, I'm afraid that I won't have enough
to handle step 45.
What am I doing? I'm not trusting God in that moment.
I'm not trusting his sovereign plan
that he knows what he's doing.
I'm not trusting his provision in the moment.
I feel like I have to be in control in order to prevent
or restrict the danger that I see coming on step 45.
Jesus had some words to say about that
in Matthew chapter six.
He says, therefore I tell you,
do not be anxious about your life, what you'll eat
or what you'll drink, nor about your body.
What you will put on is not life more than food
and the body more than clothing.
Look at the birds of the air.
They neither sow nor reap nor gather into barns.
Yet your heavenly Father feeds them.
Are you not of more value than they?
And which of you by being anxious can add a single hour
to his span of life?
Why are you anxious about clothing?
Consider the lilies of the field. They they grow.
They neither toil nor spin.
Yet I tell you, even Solomon in all his glory was
not arrayed like one of these.
But if God so closed the grass of the field,
which today's alive tomorrow is thrown into the oven,
will he not much more clothe you
of you, owe you of little faith.
Therefore, do not be anxious
saying, what shall we eat?
What shall we drink? What shall we wear the Gentiles seek?
After all these things, your heavenly Father knows
that you need them all, but seek first the kingdom of God
and his righteousness
and all, all these things will be added to you.
Therefore do not. This is it right here.
Do not be anxious about tomorrow,
for tomorrow will be anxious for itself.
Sufficient for the day is its own trouble,
not step 45, you're on step one.
That's what you need to be concerned about right now.
That's what you need to focus on, right?
And notice what Jesus said there.
He promised that each day will have trouble.
Yet don't forget the other promise we saw today in one
Corinthians one, eight, which says
that the Lord Jesus Christ will sustain you to the end.
That's a promise too, right?
So he promised troubles coming every day,
but the promise is also he'll sustain you.
Now, that does not mean that he won't protect you from
criticism at work or from cancer and you
or your family, but
here's what you can trust.
You don't know. Maybe that stuff's coming for you
and for me, and maybe that's going to happen.
But here's what you can trust that in the middle of all of
that, because he sustains you,
there is still some unique goodness
to be experienced in the middle
of it as you go through it.
And this changes everything, doesn't it
Like we can be satisfied in him, even as we wait
for the revealing, even as we wait through the troubles
and we deal with trials because the Lord Jesus Christ is
purifying us in it and he's sustaining us in it.
That's how we can be satisfied.
All the disappointments, all the discontent
that we might face in our daily lives.
He's exchanging that for satisfaction in him.
He's proving to us He is enough for us.
But that's the thing about hope.
We've all been there at some point where we know
that when we're confident something is coming in the future,
it sure seems to change the way we act and think here
and now when you know that trip is coming
or when you know that gift is going to be given, you can,
you can change the way you think and act even today.
And so it's good for us to be reminded
of God's faithfulness in the past, his faithfulness
to us in the present.
But what will he do in the future?
How is he faithful tomorrow and the next day
and the forever, just as much as he has been and is today?
What will he do in the future?
Well, I've already said it a little bit,
but it's what Paul wrote here in verse seven.
We're all waiting for the revealing
of our Lord Jesus Christ.
We're on that day. As the scriptures refer to many times,
that verse eight says here on that day,
the eastern sky will split open and we will finally see him.
He will meet us face to face.
This is what Jesus is going to do.
We don't know when, but we know it's going to happen.
In fact, it's what Hebrews 9 27 28 says
that just as it is appointed for man to die once and
after that comes judgment, the bench of the judge.
So Christ having been offered once to bear the sins
of many will appear a second time not to deal with sin,
but to save those who are eagerly waiting for him.
I don't want us to skim over that last phrase too quickly,
eagerly waiting for him.
Is that, is that the orientation of our hearts,
this anxious expectation of seeing him?
Like we wake up in the morning
and we think maybe today's the day I get to see Jesus
is, is that how we posture our hearts?
I confess to you that that's
so often not on my heart and mind.
Now, maybe when life is especially hard,
I tend to think that way.
But the majority of times it's kind
of in the background if there at all.
So why? Why is it not right here?
Why is it not on the forefront of our minds?
If we're not eagerly expecting, eagerly wait,
why is it not there?
Well, maybe because we, we might believe
that he won't actually come back.
We don't believe it because we've been burned
so many times in this life
by unfulfilled promises from people we love and trusted.
And they kept saying this and they didn't come through.
And now we're thinking, well, maybe not.
Maybe Jesus isn't actually telling us the truth,
or it seems so delayed.
It's just been so long, man.
Maybe it's not actually gonna happen.
But remember verse nine was just say,
God is faithful.
You've seen it in the past. You've seen it in your life.
God is faithful. Faithful is God, right?
Remember, this is the point. He always has been, always is.
And so we can know, he always will be faithful
Or maybe, maybe his return is not on the forefront
of our minds because we kind of like it here.
We kind of enjoy it here.
In fact, I've had a number of young people along the
ministry years I've served, come to me over the years
and say that they, they sure wanted Jesus to come back,
but they wanted him to wait till after the wedding.
And I am not dogging on that group specifically.
'cause I probably said that too.
'cause we all do it in some ways, don't we?
We all do it in ways.
We're like, boy, I really want you to come back Jesus,
but I sure wanna see my grandkids.
I sure want to graduate. Like whatever it is, we come up
with all these things.
What it shows That we're too comfortable here,
that this is home to us rather than our true home.
That There's a little bit of idolatry in our hearts.
That we love things here more than we love the
Lord who's coming back.
I read this from Piper this week.
He said, there is a phony faith
that once only escaped from hell,
but has no desire for Christ.
That does not save.
And it does not produce an eager expectation
for Christ to come.
It would rather that Christ not come for as long as possible
so that it can have as much of this world as possible.
But the faith that really holds on to Christ as the treasure
and hope and joy is the faith that makes us along
for Christ to come.
And that is the faith that saves,
take Christ not just as your fire insurance policy,
but as your eagerly awaited bridegroom and friend and Lord.
So some of us are waiting or are not waiting eagerly
because we may not believe or
because we love this world too much still.
Others are just hoping for the end to come
to finally get rid of all this mess, the junk in the world
and and all the sin and carnage and pain and ungodliness.
They're just like, end it Lord. Come on.
But is that the right perspective? Either?
Here's another way it's been said.
The early believers were not looking
for something to happen.
They were looking for someone to come.
Looking for the train to arrive is one thing,
but looking for someone we love to come on
that train is a whole nother matter.
Is he coming to do the sin and ungodly
and strike it all away?
Absolutely. But is that what we want?
Or do we want the the one who's coming?
See, that's what strengthens our hearts.
That's what sustains our lives, is not just
that everything's gonna be made right, it's the fact
that we have a faithful God who we love,
who's returning for us to take us home with him forever.
That's why Psalm 27, 4 says, wait for the Lord,
be strong and take courage.
Wait for the Lord. In other words, wait
for the one you love.
He's coming back. So stand strong today
because not only is he gonna meet us in that moment,
here's another part of it.
He's going to purify us and perfect us in that moment.
We've been building to this right past,
taking care of present.
He's working on us. Some days coming, he's going
to perfect us.
What He's made us already, these sanctified saints,
blameless the image of Christ, he's shaping us into daily.
One day he's gonna finally finish that,
and it's that day when it's coming.
Philippians 1, 6, 1 of my favorite verses, I'm sure of this,
that he who began a good work in you will surely bring
it to completion at the day of Jesus Christ.
So if he started a work in your life, if he's starting
to do something like he's saved you, he is saving you,
and one day he will save you.
If he started it, he's going to finish it.
Take heart in that.
And because all of this is coming,
because we know Jesus will meet us,
because we know he will perfect us instead of the fear
that comes with the future.
What we instead can see is hope,
is fear of the unknown.
Like that. Fear creeps in
because we don't even know what's gonna happen this
afternoon, let alone tomorrow.
It takes one phone call
to change your whole life, doesn't it?
One doctor's appointment, one instance on the highway.
It takes one moment and what you had thought and dreamed
and planned is totally changed.
We have no idea what's gonna happen.
So that's where fear starts to creep in Step 45,
fear over that.
Instead of fear though, because this is true,
because God is utterly dependable, we can exchange
that fear with hope.
The fear that we have
because of the future in our normal worldly, earthly,
fleshly lives that can be exchanged with hope,
the blessed hope that Titus two 13 identifies
as the appearing of the glory of our great God
and Savior Jesus Christ.
That's where hope comes from.
So do you remember how we started this sermon today?
The thought experiment where you look at your past, present,
future, but in doing
so you've removed the faithfulness of God.
What did we get from that?
When we look at our past, we get regret, shame.
Look at our present. What? What do we get?
We get discontent,
disappointment, and we look at our future.
We get a lot of fear over the unknown,
but now we've come back around
and we've been reminded of the faithfulness
of God, past, present, future.
We see how he has done it.
What ought to be different now
because God is faithful,
he exchanged the regret with forgiveness.
He's exchanged the discontent with satisfaction,
and he's exchanged the fear with hope.
That's how he sustains us. Church.
In the midst of all the problems that I have, here's
to the problems I don't have anymore.
I don't have a fear of separation from God forever.
I don't have the fear of his absence today,
and I don't have the fear of an insecure future anymore.
I know that in the midst of all of it,
because God is faithful in all of what I'm experiencing.
He has some unique goodness for me in it.
We just need to look to him for it.